il enchaîne les entrevues depuis son
retour d'irak sur sa guerre contre le
groupe armé état islamique
les chu young boys cet ex militaire du
22e régiment se fait appeler ouali pour
des questions de sécurité à chaque
tribune
il répète cette phrase clé mon empreinte
pas c'était la caméra pendant un peu
plus de trois mois où aller a combattu
le groupe armé ita islamique au sol il
voulait se rendre tout d'abord en syrie
finalement elle a joint des soldats
kurdes en irak les pechmergas ils
seraient environ une douzaine d'ex
militaires canadiens et américains à
s'être porté volontaire leur impact
militaire minimes reconnaît l'ex tireurs
d'élite g m'a dit je t'aime ainsi chaque
goutte d'eau se croit une saisie à la
peau dossier oui c'est une goutte d'eau
mais c'est comme ceux qu'ont fait les
hausses hier une petite contribution à
la fox est une différence
or ces images captées peuvent avoir un
certain effet affirment ces spécialistes
l'action militaire elle est pour moi une
très relative l'action symbolique par
contre est trop contente
non seulement les participer à ces
combats l'armée à revenir puis à dire je
les fais il est fait je les filme et
regarder ce qu'on peut faire
les images que vous voyez sont celles
que wali a tourné afin de produire un
documentaire pour sensibiliser la
population canadienne à ce conflit
une population qui pourrait en retour
convaincre le gouvernement fédéral de
déployer des troupes au sol les chansons
naissent croit cet universitaire
l'impact il est pas immédiat n'est pas
visible mois l'impact que je vois c'est
un coup d'épée dans l'eau à mon avis
mais l'opinion publique me roux pas
entendre parler d'une intervention armée
surtout dans le contexte le gouvernement
libéral a promis en campagne électorale
de mettre fin aux frappes aériennes
ou ali fait partie de ces combattants
qui ont beaucoup d'attentes envers
ndjolé sli l'ancien commandant de
l'armée de terre élu député libéral 19
octobre dernier des militaires et ex
militaire qui espère que tout comme en
afghanistan les forces canadiennes vont
jouer un rôle marquant dans ce conflit
contre le groupe armé est un islam hic
ici qu est ce n'est radio canada québec